Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck denn
der sorgt für ein Wirtschaftswunder aber
leider nicht bei uns ähm immer mehr
Großkonzerne wie VW BASF verlegen ihre
Produktion ins Ausland jetzt sorgt auch
der Verkauf des Familienunternehmen zu
Wissmann an einem amerikanischen
Klimaanlagen Hersteller für Entsetzen
für 12 Milliarden geht die
wärmepumpensparte den us-konsent careal
global und da würde ich direkt gerne
Frau Wagenknecht fragen was ist da los
und wird Deutschland die
industrialisiert also die Gefahr ist
zumindest sehr groß und mit jeder
Behinderten Idee die habe ich unter die
Leute bringen will wächst die Gefahr
dass Deutschland in 10 Jahren nicht mehr
zu den führenden Industrieländern gehört
und da kommen ja viele Dinge zusammen
natürlich hat das schon vor der von der
unter der letzten Regierung begonnen das
betrifft ja auch die Bildungspolitik
viele andere Fragen aber was wir jetzt
erleben mit den extremen Energiepreisen
mit den Regeln die jetzt geschaffen
werden mit einem völligen Verzicht auf
eine irgendwie konsistente
Industriepolitik was wir bräuchten